to completely switch gears from Italy uh
I watched something interesting
uh it wasn't just the Mario movie
I saw a Thai hentai
oh God what yes okay I think I know
which one it is okay because I watched
it too
where was my invite I I I don't know you
watched it either I mean it's got to be
right like it's yeah how many are there
okay okay okay why yeah okay yeah to
preface okay I feel like maybe there's
something in my blood for me to be a
[__] degenerate because I've been to
like you know uh Anime conventions in
Singapore and stuff like that before and
uh you go to the artists alley and I
remember going to uh AFA or something uh
and you know other conventions before
that yeah uh and going to the artist
alley and every cultured artist like I
would I would hear them talk and
everyone was Thai and I was like ah My
People my my people drawing all these uh
cultured fan arts right so I had an ink
link that there were a lot of like
talented cultured artists and animators
in Thailand and uh this all came uh this
all came to light when I was just
browsing the internet and I saw what I
thought was just like a normal hentai
yeah me too yeah I uh I clicked the
episode so the hentai is called my
mother all right
Hey listen I was uh it's like perfectly
as SEO generated yeah in Connor's knees
yeah it was called my mother and like
number two I noticed it was weird
because it was a hint I had never seen
before it was just released and
everything was like uncensored and I was
like what there's Sunset hentai now what
the [__] is going on so I clicked the
episodes and I'm like this isn't
Japanese wait oh hold on a second I
don't want to say I know what this I
recognize this language this is this is
my mother's tongue
and honestly like genuinely the
animation was actually like pretty damn
it's very good really yeah yeah it was
like the character designs were so like
actually damn good the animation was
great but oh my God I could not my my
dick has never been more flaccid in my
life
[__] I'd never like I never have heard
Thai voice acting in the context of like
hentai
it was I I couldn't okay so the plot
okay with with a plot it's [__] awful
as well yeah
um with with a plot like my mother right
it's it's about it's about a guy and his
mum okay and uh hearing hearing a guy
talk to his mum and his mum talk to him
with the same phrases that I've heard
like in my household as well was just
like ah this is uh I was like oh oh my
God
oh yeah they're blood related as well
which I was kind of like not on board
with yeah yeah that's nah that's kind of
weird now now you understand why I'm not
into Mill fan time because it's the
exact same thing I'm just like I just
don't I don't want to think about my
household yeah I don't need it to be
like the [__] their [__] mom I just
needed to be a hot lady who's older like
I don't know I don't even have kids
there's a difference like I don't need
them to be the mom they were like oh no
this is the mom I'm like no no it's
weird yeah it's in Thai which is not to
be rude to tie but it does not sound hot
it does not I will agree with you with
that uh I think one of the big things as
well is that the voice acting sounds
exactly the same as every Thai soap
opera I've ever seen but then you bring
that to the context of uh a guy and his
mother having sex and I'm just like Ugh
okay uh incest bad oh my God this is uh
I get it I get it now I cannot turn off
this part of my brain this is horrible
as incestors might maybe bad yeah but
I'm like uh yeah when you hear Japanese
do you do you have like a separation
between like okay this is Anime versus
this is stuff I used to hear in my
household because like I would hear like
certain phrases in this thing and I was
I was just like hearing hearing the mum
say hey hey son come over here hey son
and I'm just like oh don't don't say it
like that don't don't come on come on
man come on I mean kinda but like you
know I think at this point I've watched
enough anime and handtime in my life
where I'm like this is clearly this is
completely two separate things yeah and
it's like you know none of them sound
like anyone I know so it's like that
definitely helps okay if it was someone
I knew voicing it then I'd be like
no thank you turn that [__] off so hi
people uh you are so close you're
pleased please please please hire a
dubbing company I I I I beg of you I beg
of you I know I don't want to understand
that [__]
it's just called my mother I don't know
how I found it I think it was just on a
hentai website in general and it popped
up and I was like oh okay cool yeah I
think I'm like oh I have seen this image
yeah yeah like there's no way I haven't
I haven't watched it but I was like this
is Ty that's Ty yeah it looks good
though yeah actually looks good doesn't
it yeah why couldn't it just be her with
someone else like that right right
preferable yeah because I was really I
was like there's no way a hentai about
Mouse release and I didn't know about it
already
I have the entire release schedule I
know everything that's coming out yeah I
do I I got it like with the website I
normally watch hentai on it just tells
you when shit's coming out and I was
like yeah normally like in my head I'm
like I don't [__] like put it in my
calendar being like this [__] out
prepare to get away I forgot to put in
but uh like a mental note sometimes you
know you you find out a hentai's being
released and you're like oh [__] I like
I like the first one that was hard yeah
yeah
I can't remember how I discovered I
think it was actually Twitter
yeah I don't know so I don't know if
it's just a me thing or my timeline
thing what's going on with Thailand
right now I saw that [__] JoJo thing
you retweeted as well uh yeah I have no
I have no idea I saw it earlier before
you retweeted I was like oh that's sick
yeah yeah and then you retweet her it's
like this is legit and I'm like
cap I mean I could I mean I could see
Thailand doing it like Thailand kind of
just like as you saw when you guys went
to Thailand with the [__] huge
Captain America huge Mario statue we
just like taking like random culture and
just like inserting it whenever we can
even if it makes no sense and being like
look for the Mario movie yeah like like
the Mario movie itself right yeah
um but yeah like it's it's so I could
definitely see uh a politician just
basically using JoJo uh JoJo kind of
like art to uh I mean he's got my vote
that's for sure I mean it's uh it's it
was are you approaching me it's just the
polls yeah it's just me walking to the
ballad I mean I would say I would love
for politics to do more of this stuff uh
outside of outside of Thailand I would
uh probably make people more interested
in there or Japan like sometimes they
cosplay right the people who are going
for yeah sure yeah well one it was uh
one of the weirdest things is watching a
manga artist I [__] grew up with uh
running for us
yeah and he's like first thing I'm gonna
do when I go to office power to all
tacos and everyone's like yeah boy
that's why he's a goat yeah I remember
like seeing my Twitter where he was he
just had like uh when he was running he
had like an office or something in
Akihabara and I was like this is this is
so surreal right now this is my like I I
I read this man's manga uh he was the
Harem gods and now he's just running for
office like where are we gonna go next
you know but I suppose I suppose that's
not the weirdest thing that's happened
in the world now that I think about it
yeah that's not weird at all yeah yeah
yeah
someone being a little quirky isn't it
it was bound to happen in Japan
eventually yeah for sure yeah like stuff
that we say is we like is was weird like
10 years ago is like totally sane now
which is like the bars Twitter really
changed the bar for what weird is and oh
my God Twitter lately as well I'm just
like oh my God this is worse than
PornHub and Lively on one website this
is great yeah yeah it's it's it's uh I
have no idea what the [__] is going on
with you right now